ser docente de la espol qué interesante
pregunta
no es fácil en un contexto pensar que
cualquier persona que se ha dedicado a
la docencia y la investigación esté en
un contexto de docencia policial
es muy bonito contar mi historia porque
realmente yo llego a la docencia porque
me gusta porque me gusta la docencia
porque por qué porque llegar a la
docencia cuando eso dicen que es que él
solo da plata y que solo a prestigio en
la sociedad como la nuestra
llegó la docencia por cariño pero
también por repulsión cuando yo era un
poco más joven tuve una maestra que me
odiaba y yo también lo odiaba por el
hecho de que no le gustaba que yo
participara porque yo siempre me gustaba
leer y eso es la invitación que el agua
a los estudiantes hay que leer ya que es
mucho más adelante del profesor y esta
señora nos ridiculizaba entonces no se
inhibía para poder participar pero bueno
nosotros la queríamos tanto que le
hacíamos varios meses y la odia vamos en
una forma bastante sigilosa y llegué a
esta tarea después de muchos años en
otras universidades y la vida lo pone a
uno donde debe ser y con quién debe ser
y llego coincidencialmente a esta
universidad y todo el mundo se pregunta
pero
como así queda la universidad de la
policía la policía luego tiene
universidad algunos policías piensan
luego los policías discierne pues
créanme que sí y de las grandes
satisfacciones que en estos últimos seis
años he tenido como profesional y como
docente es haber estado en esta
universidad de la policía inició con mis
estudiantes de la policía
en dos baterías en este momento política
pública y sociología de la seguridad
política pública así que un estudiante
de la policía sabe de política públicas
eso está reservado para unos cuantos y
unos pocos es decir con grandes alcances
y grandes resultados hemos tenido en
materia de política pública
la política pública no es tan fácil
enseñar pasarles unos libros que lean no
nosotros hemos hecho un ejercicio muy
reflexivo muy interesante con estos
muchachos estos altos oficiales quienes
compartimos la construcción del
conocimiento y gracias a esa profesora
que hoy en día la quiero mucho porque me
enseñó al cómo no debo enseñar
hemos hecho un ejercicio reflexivo con
los otros policías en política pública
por ejemplo hemos creado cosas
brillantes para efectos de proponerle
soluciones al estado que es la política
pública la política pública es la
posibilidad de crear acciones y
respuestas de parte del estado a
necesidades sociales y en materia se
envía a todos los días aparecen
necesidades sociales
y es muy interesante observar como en la
academia a partir de una serie de
propuestas se construyen alternativas
diferentes nuestro sur antes de la
policía son reflexivos son analíticos y
son críticos
hemos cambiado ese modelo de que el
profesor sabía todo de que el profesor
entregaba todo y que era simplemente el
estudiante era el receptor aquí en
nuestra institución policial en esta
universidad
hemos encontrado valiosísimos aportes
para la función entonces hay que
desmitificar y yo se lo digo como
docente que yo traiga un concepto
completamente errado de que en la
universidad de la policía no había
reflexión no había aporte no había
críticas creo que eso es una de las
anécdotas que más ha marcado mi vida y
que he podido llevar a otros escenarios
académicos
en cuanto a la sociología de la
seguridad pero qué es eso de la
sociología y de la seguridad son como
second min soo kim pues casi nada que es
el aporte al oficial al líder policial
para que comprenda el contexto la
sociedad en la cual se va a desarrollar
pero es que bieber es que policía no
tiene acercamiento a la sociedad como
que no es la primera institución en la
que todo el mundo pensamos se nos rompió
una muela llamen a la policía se me cayó
el día / llamen a la policía en todo en
nuestro país siempre es así y qué
importante que dotar al miembro de la
policía como líder social en el
cumplimiento del conocimiento y en la
comprensión de la sociología de la
sociología de la seguridad que logramos
respuestas efectivas para las
necesidades sociales de la sociedad y
además concientizar al miembro de la
institución policial como líder público
como líder policial para que se
encuentre en entornos difíciles y
diferentes soluciones prontas para que
tenga la capacidad de liderar y de dar
respuestas efectivas en entornos
diferentes pero con respuestas para que
la sociedad asuma realmente ese
compromiso de corresponsabilidad
no es fácil realmente enfrentarse a todo
llegar a dictar una clase en una
institución como la de la policía debe
ser muy fácil si es fácil porque porque
el respeto porque hay
se ejerce la autoridad de docente en el
buen sentido con recepción y con respeto
pero también es fácil porque se aporta
mucho porque se convierte el estudiante
en un
grant
el proveedor de conocimientos y de
construcción de conocimientos en esta
universidad la gran experiencia que he
tenido yo es que no soy el docente que
da sino que el docente que recibe que
construye mutuamente y que además está
formando los grandes líderes sociales
que tienen que transformar nada menos y
nada más que el tema de la seguridad y
consideró que ese ha sido el papel más
importante y que invito a los futuros
docentes que quieran vincularse en esta
institución a que coadyuden a la
formación de líderes policiales para las
respuestas efectivas a esa problemática
social desmitifiquemos quitemos del
inconsciente que el policía no piensa
que el policía no se forma que el
policía no aporta que el policía es
irreflexivo yo creo que esa es una de
las grandes estrellas que tiene el
docente común convencional de que cuando
se acerca a la institución policial se
enfrenta a grandes líderes pensadores
críticos analíticos y aportantes si me
preguntaran en este momento cuáles ha
sido el valor agregado para mi formación
personal y de formación profesional el
haber tenido la fortuna de ingresar a
esta institución universitaria es la
capacidad de crítica y de análisis y de
aporte que tienen esos muchachos estas
hombres y mujeres que pertenecen a la
institución policial y que hoy por hoy
no va a ser fácil van a darse cuenta la
sociedad en la transformación y en el
gran aporte que tienen estos líderes y
líderes y lideresas en el cambio de la
sociedad va a ser un trabajo del textil
de largo tiempo pero sé que dentro de
muy poco nos vamos a empezar a ver ya
cosechar esos resultados y es eso yo
creo que anecdóticamente a veces se dice
que en mis clases no se aprende mucho
pero se divierte porque es que es una
forma también lúdica de que el
estudiante se exprese y que todas sus
opiniones son válidas
y la invitación es a que construyamos ya
que aportemos desde esta importante
institución universitaria la
transformación social no es difícil no
es imposible es sólo cuestión de
enamorarse deben compenetrarse con esta
institución y vamos a ver que nuestra
sociedad muy pronto va a tener grandes
resultados